Pay.
What's going on is bill burn is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and just checking in on you so I couldn't give you a big
one.
I fucked up my voice going all the way back to San Jose Cruz,
uh,
back the San Jose gigs.
I don't know what I did.
I know what I did.
I was imitating somebody yelling.
I was having too much fun.
I didn't come from my diaphragm and I fucking choked up and I just fucking blew
the voice out.
That's what I did.
I always sped the main rotor in my fucking throat is what happened.
So now I've got to go eat.
She,
you know,
I gotta drink a little shrill Coty,
you know.
Um,
anyways,
what's going on?
How are you guys doing?
You're feeling good.
I get energized and excited about the fucking weekend.
Um,
I've actually been working out finally.
I'm still eating like a fucking moron,
so I haven't been dropped that much weight,
but I feel better.
You know what it is?
I'm at this fucking age.
I swear to God.
I have one sip of this or one bite of that and it just fucks me.
It's unbelievable.
I swear to God,
if I didn't work out,
I would be like,
I would look like every other fucking moron walking around the mall.
That's all it is.
I'm really starting to believe that a lot of people now I was kid knew we shove
a bunch of cake down our throats.
I just,
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
I know.
It's just weird how I said that.
I eat like a fucking Olympian until about three,
four in the afternoon.
I work out like a soccer mom,
but I eat like a fucking Olympian,
cause my shoulders,
my shoulders coming around,
by the way.
Um,
so I'm doing like the elliptical and that type of shit,
but for the front up until about three,
I fucking kill it,
you know?
And then the weakness starts coming in like a fucking cold front,
like a rainstorm.
The clouds started forming around three or three 30 in the afternoon and I feel
myself getting weak on,
come on bill,
come on.
Veggies,
veggies.
Fessy shoved down your pie hole.
Let's meet battening.
That's me putting fucking plywood over the windows.
You know,
before I do something stupid.
And then just,
you know,
I dunno,
I keep trying to do this thing where I'm going to be done eating around six
o'clock at night and then just drink waters the rest of the time.
And if I get hungry,
I'm just going to have a little bit of celery and I know salaries on the dirty
dozen list of fucking pesticides.
It's basically anything where they just spray it directly on like cantaloupes.
Good.
Cause they spray the shit on,
you know the fucking a Bola,
you know what I mean?
The AIDS virus,
whatever the fuck they do to keep the mosquitoes away,
they spray,
spray it right on the fucking candle of,
but it doesn't get to the part that you eat and you don't lick the outside of
it.
You know the way fat show licked is the bottom of the sneakers in the MTV cribs.
I will never get over that.
It's like dude,
those were made in a sweatshop just cause you to walk around New York.
And if you have no fucking idea,
don't get a tetanus shot job.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
the fuck was I talking about?
So salary,
you know,
cause I'll spray it right on it cause it doesn't have a husk or whatever the
fuck it is.
Um,
so this person tells you who go get organic salary,
salary,
just get our Kerrick salary.
I wanted it to be like lay,
how to fuck.
You don't know where the fuck any of this shit is.
I think it all comes from the same God damn farm.
And they go ahead,
get with that one looks greener than those ones.
Call them on organic.
That's about ready to go back and say that's organic.
And they'll think that the reason why it's rotting is because,
uh,
you know,
because it's so fucking fresh.
I Dunno.
So at night I tried to do like the salary have just a little bit half a spoonful
of sugar,
no half full,
half a spoonful of peanut butter to try to get me through and uh,
you know,
then you just go to bed like upset.
That's what happened.
If you're eating right,
you go to upset,
you're not in a good mood.
All right.
Now,
a lot of fucking nutritionists,
dieticians,
fucking personal trainers,
fucking crossfitters and all that.
It say like,
no,
if you read it,
you shouldn't feel hungry at all because you body will be full of all the new
cheesy knees.
Any movie craving a,
shut the fuck up and get tight clothes.
Okay.
Dressing like a Goddamn Eczema to do fucking curls.
Workout clothes at the dumbest,
stupidest shit.
Okay.
I was watching an old odd couple boto.
Ooh,
no.
My favorite part of that song is when the horn section kicks in ballet to do,
to do bow
wow.
Back then when it was actually a fucking orchestra,
it wasn't some guy with a laptop fucking pumping his fist like he's going to
reboot the Arsenio show for the third fucking time.
It wasn't like that.
It was actual,
it was somebody that practice the fucking Trump bomb.
Yeah.
Since he was knee high fight and the dust bowl during the depression right
before fucking Pearl Harbor and he had to beat out 50,000 other Tuba players.
Everybody trying to put their own stamp on down,
but up buddy,
you know,
you sitting out there all fucking nervous.
No one,
his dad's going to give him the belt if he doesn't fucking book it.
Right.
Okay.
He's on the other side of the door just listening to other people audition,
you know,
it's like fuck the guy nailed it.
Um,
I was watching,
I'm getting off track here.
I was watching that show and uh,
Oscar,
yeah,
Oscar w had come from the gym and he just had on a gray sweatshirt and gray
sweatpants.
He didn't have to go in there all fucking aerodynamic.
Like he was doing a time trial in the Tour de France.
All of this fucking shit that Nike makes.
Who's kidding?
Who that children making the Nike factory,
you know,
before they tried to jump out the fucking window.
Or is that apple?
I have no idea.
It's all a legend.
I don't,
they did it.
You know,
it's fake news.
There's children are happy.
They put the nets outside the window because they enjoy jumping into them.
It's a religious holiday.
Um,
Oh God,
I gotta work on my Trump.
I got to work my Trump.
It's a whole you,
it's rough,
you know.
Um,
that's all the fuck you need now.
Everybody's got all,
they got all the fucking,
but he's walking around dressed like captain America.
Oh my God.
I saw a shit show at the mall yesterday.
An absolute fucking,
she was such a shit show.
I actually was looking around for someone to be trying to film me for my
reaction.
Um,
I had gone to the mall again,
that's twice in a week.
I never go to the mall twice in a fucking week.
And this time I went to the grove.
Now if you don't,
if you don't live in La,
okay.
The Grove is basically,
it's like going to times square on New Year's Eve,
except it's a mall.
It's a fucking nightmare.
All right.
But I was going down there because I'm a man.
Um,
Deanna Adler,
Steven Adler's mom who wrote,
uh,
the wonderful book,
um,
well actually tragic book.
And then it comes out,
this sucks,
you know,
it starts off with sunshine,
it gets really fucking cloudy for a couple hundred pages and then it comes out
again.
It's a great book.
Um,
called us sweet child of mine.
And,
uh,
she was doing a book signing as I said,
I was going to be down there and um,
you know,
so I went down there and the book signing was great.
And uh,
our son's,
uh,
Steven and Jamie came down.
That dude,
Steven Adler is fucking hilarious.
It was a huge crowd.
Thank you to everybody who showed up,
who listened to my podcast and went down there.
Um,
I think,
you know,
had a couple of Ammon podcast's listeners down there.
I ran into,
um,
through,
he was fucking killing,
killing,
say whatever he wanted to some woman in the crowd.
She's like,
Stephen,
do you remember me back in the day I used to stand out from the rainbow.
He's like,
I had,
I did I fuck you said that in Barnes and nobles.
Barnes and noble.
Is it,
I don't know.
I don't read Barnes and noble or nobles,
NBA Final Stanley Cup,
final Stanley Cup finals.
I can't remember.
And in this fucking bookstore,
in a microphone,
he said,
um,
just complete,
might be like a comedian that just didn't give a shit whether they ever work the
club again,
it fucking amazing.
And uh,
he absolutely destroyed and uh,
and they sold a bunch of books.
So a order one today,
it's an incredible read,
man.
I'm telling you,
it's fucking brutal.
It's fucking like if you already read his,
his w.
Dot.
Stevens was brutal enough.
But now to hear the mother's side going through the pain to try and help them
out.
I tell you,
I'm going to be honest with you,
I haven't gotten through it yet.
So fucking brutal.
It is.
I just got into the part where Stephen starts going off the rails and I'm just
like,
Oh man,
I gotta go like one chapter at a time.
Um,
in other words,
she pulls no punches.
So,
uh,
definitely check that out if you can.
So anyways,
back to this shit show.
So I'm going to the mall,
right?
And,
uh,
I pull in,
I valet,
right?
I valet like a fucking big shot because this is our,
this is to two things.
Or I don't give a fuck.
I'm usually a frugal content.
All right?
My Malcolm young tee shirt,
right.
And I don't spend any fucking money cause I know how this business works.
Right?
When you go out,
you buy something flashy.
It said,
look at him,
look at that.
Freckled can,
he thinks he made it and then they come over and walk in here and get right out
from underneath.
That's not how I'm going out.
Uh Huh.
Not,
not me.
Nope.
I'm going to buy some strip malls.
I'm going to start having some money coming in from outside of this.
Va gave me Hollywood.
It was getting home.
It's gonna be a sad ending just like everybody else's.
You know,
I'll come walking out one day on some fucking telethon,
you know,
my jaw fucking quivering uncontrollably and you guys all going to be like,
oh,
what have I used to be so young,
right?
And all you guys will have to shut it off because I'll look so bad.
It's going to remind you of your own mortality right there.
You Gulf,
there is something to look forward to this weekend.
Sorry.
Anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
so I'm walking to them,
to the mall,
okay.
And a half shirts or back or as they call them,
crop tops.
All the ladies,
all the ladies who fucking eat right or wearing them,
you know what I mean?
And I'm sure the fatties at some point are going to hate them and say that those
crop tops are sexist and you're creating an impossible body image and they're
going to blame those women.
Then actually took the time to fucking push themselves away at five o'clock and
just sit there eating celery and shit past that.
Drinking waters,
hating themselves.
You know,
here's all the people that are going to resent the crop tops where they,
huh?
Oh,
they're sitting there having a great fucking time to get gelato.
Well,
this side of caution,
that's something fat people do.
You know,
I'm fucking blowing up this spot.
I lived with a fatty,
I do.
I'm telling you,
I have fat,
French,
okay.
All of that shit.
All of those ice creams that you see,
those unholy matrimony is of fucking candy bars in ice cream.
Like who the fuck thought of that out?
The fact people,
people,
fat people,
you don't have EA,
right?
They all came up with that shit.
They all came up with that shit late at fucking night.
They're like junkies.
Okay.
And what happens is,
is after a while doing heroin isn't enough.
You got to put a little coke in there and then you got to speed balling.
So the fat fucking person speedball is when you're taking you,
if you need to get fat.
He listened to us,
you know,
it's fucking true.
You know,
you shouldn't be doing it.
you're excited.
You know you're excited,
right.
When you know you got the ice cream at home,
right?
And you stopped at the red light and you look over to the left and has that
seven 11 right?
And that demon in you just goes,
hey,
and you're driving there and go guys zag that bar.
You had vanilla ice cream at home.
I was kind of playing and he's need to take it up a notch bond.
You know what you want to do it,
you know you start crying.
Well the same you Alexis,
just to up the ice cream man.
I said make a left turn,
drive in there and get her truck not bar and you fucking turn in there and you
buy the fucking thing.
Right?
Like you going in there to rent a porn back in the nineties and element of
shame.
You don't want to make eye contact but you don't want to look away.
You know,
cause they got a couple of shit films in there.
you got to have that.
Maybe I'm going to rent sleepless in Seattle.
Look on your face,
right as you walk into the porn shop,
except it's a seven 11 and you walk in past all the other fatties and the
fucking people,
you know the junkies buying those fucking hot dogs that have been there since
fucking Ronald Reagan got shot.
Right.
You fucking go in there.
Probably grab a couple of healthy things like maybe one of their fucking
bananas.
It's still green.
You know the hand of the kid that picked it,
you know his fingerprints is still fucking on it,
right?
Then you just walk right up to the cash register at the last second.
You try to make it seem like it's,
you know,
it would lead pretty old and you've got to be uh,
yeah,
I'll
write.
Then you get the fucking stag net bar and then you take that fucking thing home.
Right?
Driving home now excited while hating yourself.
Excited.
Passing over the Double Line into your fucking house,
right?
You put on fucking Netflix and then you sit down and what are you do?
You got to take the ice cream out now this part's the hardest.
It's killing you.
You got to let the ice cream melt a little bit,
right?
So you can fucking kill him.
That God damn candy bar right in there.
Right?
That's what fatty still,
I don't want,
I'm talking about here,
so I'm at the fucking mall.
Okay,
I've got to fill up a half hour.
Okay.
I gotta have some tangents here.
You know,
you want to do a half hour with no material,
okay?
You want to try to fill it up?
Malaria.
Um,
so anyways,
so I'm walking through so this fucking,
you know,
this is another person that I can't stand,
cause I'm so God damn perfect.
Right.
The fucking person just refuses to admit that they're old.
You know,
I don't mean like just two year old,
just go sit there on the fucking couch.
I don't mean that,
you know,
definitely get out there,
get yourself Samir Butt,
you know,
put on some sunscreen.
You old fuck.
Okay.
The people that you pass a certain age and they're still trying to keep up with
young people with the styles and shit.
I saw this woman,
right?
Tragic try from fucking 80 yards.
You could tell there was no father ever in her life.
Okay.
Which is sad,
but you know,
at some point you get off,
you got to put your tits Awaiz ways and you got to look in the mirror and just
be like,
look,
all right,
so he wasn't there.
Fuck that guy.
He was a piece of shit.
I'm worth something.
This lady did not have that.
Okay.
She's fucking walking.
She is like,
I don't know what age she was.
She should have been 33.
There's something about her said 33 but she looked like 47 and she was in good
shape for her fucking A's,
but she's wearing the crop top.
Okay.
And she's doesn't have a flat stomach.
She has just that little bit of of,
uh,
it's caught belly or whatever you call it.
Right?
So it's hanging over in the front,
it's hanging on the bag and she's wearing a fucking crop top and the crop top
said bitch on it.
She's wearing these little short shorts and he's fucking high heels.
And you know,
you know,
the ladies sheets after fucking three decades is sticking yourself in horseshoe.
So you feed a beat up,
you know,
you see like the heels,
there's like those white circles from like no blood supply and shit.
And it's just like,
oh my God,
get yourself a player of flat shoes.
You know,
I'll put on a sport coat and you,
you,
you put on like some,
something flowing.
You did your title,
like young people be young.
So she fucking walks by.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
the only excuse I can make was maybe she was a hooker.
She was a hooker.
I don't have a problem with it.
God bless her.
You know what I mean?
If she had it,
she had a,
uh,
a fucking,
I don't know what you'd call it.
A God damn.
I'm charity I would give to it,
but if she's just a regular fucking person man,
shit show.
Right.
And once again,
half the reason why she was driving me nuts is it just reminded me of how old I
was.
I was like,
uh,
I am old enough that I was alive when that woman was still high.
Okay.
I'm not going to apologize for any of this shit if you're going to walk out,
okay?
You got to know your age.
All of these fucking,
you know,
you don't.
People tell you that,
you know,
you know mean fifty's the new 40,
fucking says that 50 year olds,
no,
50,
put some fucking clothes on.
Um,
dark.
Geez,
I'm on a fucking tangent here.
Not a rant.
It's not a rant.
Don't even,
it's a fucking rant.
All you guys have ruined that word rant.
Rant is your complete.
You're barely holding your shit to get a rant.
Goes with raving like hall and Oates.
Rant and raving.
All right.
This whole thing that,
hey,
he talked about the same subject and he reasonably calm tone for the last
fucking seven minutes.
He's on a rant.
You don't,
you don't see no defines it.
That fucking millennials.
And you know why that is?
Cause they wear helmets when they ride bicycles and they had play dates and they
had helicopter parents so they didn't,
didn't even know what yelling is.
God help us.
God help us when Isis that doesn't have a plane or a boat somehow figures out
how to fucking get over here from the other side of the world,
you know,
in their pajamas or whatever the fuck it is they're doing over there.
Okay.
God help us when they show up in the millennials have to fight them,
you know,
Jesus Christ.
Anyways,
so here's a good school.
Good side of it.
Aside from the fact that DNA ads are sold a bunch of fucking books.
Um,
there's a store over there out of Detroit,
Michigan and it's called Shinola.
Yeah.
So I'm going,
Shane,
I immediately,
I got to go in there because of that old school expression.
My Dad always said,
oh Christ,
that guy crazy.
He doesn't know shit from Shinola.
Wow.
That was a great one.
That one of my,
another one of my favorite and my dad got to try sec.
I could fuck up the free lunch.
Oh that one made me laugh every time you fucking said it.
Cause he always said it to the about the right person.
And then just,
just doing the math.
Like what would you have to do to fuck up a free lunch where you can literally
have the person,
you know what fuck you go somewhere else to get your food.
You know,
like what would you have to do?
The guy's giving you a free lunch,
what would you say to the guy other than thank you.
Anyways,
so there was an expression,
it was kind of a Midwest thing,
right?
I think a,
you don't know shit from Shinola,
not Shinola was a shoe Polish.
Uh,
that was in Michigan,
I believe outside of Detroit.
So the expression going,
you don't know shit from Shinola basically means you wouldn't know if he was
shining your shoes with shoe Polish to shit.
It's basically saying you're a fucking moron.
So I'm like,
all right,
Shinola.
I got to go in there.
So I come walking in there and the first thing I say to the guy who was like,
dude,
I had to come in here.
Are you familiar with the expression?
You don't know shit from Shinola?
He goes,
absolutely.
That's how we came up with the name of this store.
So I have an alley.
This company,
they make all these cool shit in America,
in Detroit,
a city that needs fucking industry,
great goddamn city,
just waiting for someone to invest in it.
Um,
they make all of this stuff.
So I fucking go in there,
dude,
you got to look these things up,
man.
Um,
aside from all the watches and all the shit they had and they had these fucking
bikes,
um,
you don't,
I'm actually gonna post the video and,
um,
and I,
I say,
hey dean,
check this shit out because I was sending it the Dean del Rey,
cause Dean del Rey is,
is a,
a a connoisseur of fine shit.
The man does not own a lot of shit,
but the shit that he owns is fine.
She top of the line shit.
So they had bicycles in there and um,
they look like paperboard bikes from the 1950s,
you know,
and I fucking did my time from third grade to ninth grade till I'd fuck.
They did it all the way up to high school,
you know.
Um,
so I always liked those bikes even though they look corny too,
a lot of people,
but it was all modern technology.
So when you quickly looked at it looked like a peewee Herman style fucking bike,
um,
with the bell and everything on it.
But then it was all this state of the ass shit.
It's kind of like a resto mod,
but like a bicycle version.
And they had this one,
it was like an 11 speed bike and all like the,
all the gear changing was like,
I can't explain where the fuck it was.
It was like a,
I guess what you'd say the differential would be on a car.
But I'm just the part that it's usually just part of the wheel.
All the gears were in there.
I'm not enough of a gear head to explain this properly.
They had the wires going into the bike.
It was all like streamline had fucking disc brakes on the front and the back,
the things were crazy.
Crazy.
So,
um,
wait a minute,
I got the fucking pamphlet right here.
I swear to God,
if I,
if I wasn't trying to downsize my life and they weren't so goddamn expensive,
I would've fucking bought one.
Um,
can't do it.
These,
these bikes,
they're really fucking,
you know,
a lot of you guys are going to think he's a nerdy looking bikes,
but I think they're fucking sick.
They got one called the Detroit aero ones,
the big SPI and one's the run.
Well.
Um,
and I'll tell you,
I'll tell you the chief,
you know,
but uh,
the fucking sick man.
That's why I wished,
you know,
I don't know how it happened.
Part of it was because there was sweatshop labor and then you had the unions and
then the unions became what the fucking cunts were.
And then everybody just said,
you know what?
Fuck you union.
And they just left the country would,
wouldn't it be great if we just made shit in this country again?
I'm telling me we got to start with,
we'd all right.
They've got to legalize it on a fucking federal level and we should make the
best fucking weed in the world.
We export that shit.
You get the whole world,
you know,
fucking buy in our weed.
They got the best,
like the,
like the White Cubans got the cigar thing locked down.
We should do that with weed.
Okay.
The government should fucking stay out of it.
Just make it legal and walk away and then tax the shit out of it.
Okay.
And have your eyes wide shut parties and fuck some other woman while you look at
your wife getting bang by his senator,
whatever it is,
you upper 1% people fucking deal.
All right,
but just walk away from that Shit.
Let us grow the before.
Can we eat in the fucking world?
We export it.
We make all that fucking money.
You get your fucking your skin with the tax,
right?
Send it to those costs over at the Federal Reserve,
whatever the fuck it is they do.
And then you know,
you pay off the war and then we just leave.
Right?
Just given the Tesla.
We just fucking will will drive those fucking cars.
Have the fucking blue blood constant run the oil industry.
Just slide them over to the electrical shit.
They'll still make the same amount of money.
Then we don't have to be over in the Middle East sticking off fucking nose and
all that shit.
We all fucking come home.
Right?
You put on a game,
you got some solar energy,
you know you got some fucking weed.
I know,
I know.
I'm over simplifying all of this.
Yeah,
I'm over simplifying all of this anyways.
I know what the fuck I'm talking about yet.
Let me,
uh,
let me do some advertising reads.
Excuse some advertising reads man,
and I gotta type in my fucking password.
It's of course vulgar.
I don't know why,
because of this fucking anger that you have in you.
I don't know what your problem is anyway.
To own,
to be this anything.
Alright,
see,
so everybody see,
so,
um,
every hear of something being a barrel of laughs.
Well,
a barrel,
it might not be enough laughs in the days of horses and buggy.
What?
Well,
a barrel might've been enough laughs in the days of horse and Buggies,
but you live now or you got to put your laughs on the cloud.
By the way,
you don't have technology.
I fucking love for those fucking headphones that guy gave me right from Bose
wireless.
I was against that shit going.
I don't need any more radio waves going into my brain,
man.
I fucking love them.
I don't give a shit what?
It's still to me.
I don't care if I turn into a fucking Zombie.
That's how convenient they are.
That's why CSO CSOS library of standup television and original content provide
streaming laughs up to 1.7 mega barrels and that's proven by science.
We see.
So you get unlimited access to seeso original series next day,
late night.
Hilarious.
Standup specials,
binge worthy classics.
Sign up now to catch brand new standup specials like the breakout special from
Faheem pronounced Fahim Anwar like Anwar Sadat.
There's no business like show business,
uh,
access CSO.
Want to ask this content from anywhere at anytime using Ios?
No.
An upside,
isn't it?
Oh yeah.
Ios,
android,
Roku,
apple TV,
Amazon fire TV windows or Xbox one Amazon fire.
That sounds like a cologne.
Ready for the punchline.
CSOS just three 99 per month.
No joke.
Three dot three 99 per month for all the comedy you want.
Anytime anywhere ad free.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com right now to sign up for one month for free with
Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout.
That's [inaudible] dot com spelled s e s o.com Promo Coper,
Jesus Christ,
seeso.com Promo Code Berg.
I'm a check out some of those,
you know,
cause everybody's on Netflix.
You know I want to be different man.
I'm over here on Cecil.
I'm on Amazon,
man.
All right.
[inaudible] beyond bs me undies.
Checking out new stream and do to do to be brds beyond these.
Your balls would be fucking gleaming.
Watch a bunch of fucking standup specials.
Rub your Tate.
I guess the material,
it's twice as soft as fucking cotton.
Yeah,
but da Ba da Ba boobooed overdue.
But elevate your underwear game to the next level with me on ds.
You've perfected your wardrobe.
But what about this stuff?
Nobody gets to see.
What about the stuff that actually touches your junk?
If you've been settling for store bought underwear,
five packs,
I have something that will change your life for the better me undies.
What's the first thing you put on the last thing you take off?
It's your underwear.
Unless you,
Matthew mcconaughey make your most important piece of clothing.
The best part it can be with me on these.
You know what?
It was just a picture of like a cop at the end of the day.
You know,
it takes off everything from the waist down and now he's completely naked,
right?
And then he takes off his gun.
They the,
excuse me,
detective,
you've got the fucking thing right?
Is that two village people for you guys?
Me and these are designed in La and made from sustainably sourced micro modal,
modal of fabric,
three times softer than cotton.
And guess what?
You can save time and money each month with a monthly subscription.
How much do you shit your pants that you got to have a monthly subscription?
Um,
I am underwear from like two presidents ago.
If you're not ready for their subscription,
that's okay.
Hey,
relax.
You can still say that's because me undies is offering you 20% off your first
pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead,
revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it once a,
you deserve it.
Get yourself some new underwear.
You fucking animal.
Once again,
that's me on [inaudible] dot com slash bro me undies.com/burp.
Um,
all right.
How much time we got left off?
28 minutes here and I got a phone call in seven minutes.
Uh,
thank you to everybody that watched the,
a tour of Phoenix from my yet to be critically acclaimed and acknowledged tours
of cities.
Uh,
I did one in San Jose.
That one's going to be coming up soon.
It's all on my youtube page,
which I of course do not have in front of me.
Just look up the,
um,
uh,
Bill Burr tour of Phoenix and you'll be able to find it.
Uh,
we'll send another link out to it.
Like I told you might fucking youtube page.
That's got to be blowing up soon.
I already have fucking animator.
I got some people doing some shit,
right?
I'll be doing tours of every fucking city.
Excuse me.
Then I go to get the hiccups,
um,
and all of that shit.
All right,
so here we go.
What can we talk about here in the final couple of minutes?
Uh,
all the Bruins,
the Bruins had their backs up against the wall.
We were,
after having a nice comfortable fucking lead,
we'd up to like a fifth seat.
We tumbled all the way down to an eighth seed one ahead.
The Tampa Bay lightning.
All right.
And I wasn't paying a timber edge tension to tamp out was just watching the
Bruins lose.
And then I looked at the fucking standards because one night I was watching the
lightning playing the black hawks and the Blackhawks dog.
We're up fucking four to one,
and you know,
the lightening start coming back and I'm fucking enjoying it.
Oh Shit.
Four to two.
Wow.
Shit.
What the fuck would it break game?
I realized that that was hurting my team and they ended up winning in overtime.
They get two points and they will,
they will one point behind us.
So we beat the fucking,
uh,
we'd be Long Island,
right?
Long Island would be the islanders said playing Brooklyn,
figure that one out.
And um,
and then Tuesday night we beat the fucking pray.
So tonight,
who do we got?
The fucking staff,
such a Boston week prejudice stats.
Um,
that's who we're playing tonight.
And in the lightening have the Detroit Redwings sore and not having a good year,
but they,
you know,
they always got some fucking Sergei Federoff next phenom coming up.
You know,
they kind of like,
uh,
the Pittsburgh penguins where they just,
they got the fucking,
they got that down man.
Somehow they,
you know,
I mean the penguins are crazy too.
They had fucking Mario Lemieux and Jaromir Jaga then he had like a fucking 10
year drought,
15 year drought or whatever,
and then they come back with fucking Gino and sit,
you know,
and you know,
something that the Bruins could be like that if we didn't fucking ship 'em out
all the time.
You know,
we had Tyler Sagan,
hey,
what'd you have a fucking cores light a get out of town buddy.
That's when,
that's not what we do here.
And this racist town.
This is an upstanding community.
So we shipped him out and now look what we got.
We got fucking Pasta Knoxx become,
uh,
you know,
he's become a super sad Brad Marshawn.
You know,
it's just like what a Tyler was still there.
You could essentially be rolling three fucking,
I don't know shit about hockey,
but I mean,
I don't know.
We're always doing shit like that.
Look at you.
Look at all the goals.
Joel Cho Thorton scored in San Jose for why they never won shit.
We didn't get shit for him in the fucking trade.
We just didn't want to pay him.
But anyways,
anyways,
that's not important.
We have the stars tonight.
Okay.
The stars at night are big and deep in and up Texas.
Um,
but Dallas is not deep in the heart of Texas.
It's right out there in the open.
So we're going to win tonight,
I hope.
But you never know.
They got Jamie van,
they gave fucking Patrick's Shap,
Patrick shap on the Dallas says,
um,
the next f one race by the way,
is in,
I'm not this Sunday,
it's going to be next Sunday.
And that's in China in dokie.
And by the way,
speaking of China,
um,
I got satellite radio now.
So I finally get to listen to had the Howard stern show again.
And his wife has some sort of cause and you know,
I'm always,
you know,
worry of a cause through.
I only listened to half of it and I had to turn the fucking channel would was
describing.
They got some day over there or I don't know what the fuck they doing with dogs
where they torture them.
They scare the shit out of them.
They think that they have like adrenaline,
you know,
high anxiety.
It makes the meat taste better.
They fucking torture him in front of the other dogs to make it more for the dogs
here.
The [inaudible] I don't want to give you the rest of it.
It made me sick to my fucking stomach.
So there's a petition that you can sign to try to get the fuck animals that are
doing that shit to stop on a Howard Stern Dotcom.
You just scroll down and uh,
you know I had to sign that shit cause uh,
and even if you got to do something about how the fuck can you do that to a dog,
you know what I mean?
I know what all you vegetarians going to say?
Well the shit they do to cows and all that.
You know what,
you're fucking right.
Isn't there a way to just,
you know,
fucking give a cow to behind the year when it's not even like paying attention.
The thing is,
is once you kill one,
the other sense it and everyday it's fucking brutal.
But you know the end of the day,
a fucking hamburgers delicious.
I don't know.
But you know you can,
why don't you just fucking have some cows?
Maybe it's because they have a billion people over there.
So there's not enough cows for people.
I don't,
I don't fucking know.
But I love dogs.
So if you love dogs,
yeah.
Howard stern.com sign the fucking petition anyways.
And then as far as,
um,
motorcycle racing goes,
I'm going to try to get into this shit cause he's racist at Nice increase races.
Got a little,
Christopher Walken is rice is there.
I'm not going to do Christopher Walken.
All right.
Listen to fucking Craig gas or fucking Jaymar.
Uh,
the next,
uh,
I think the first one of that season,
if you want to get into racing now,
motorcycle racing is fucking insane cause they still bump each other and shit
and they're on motorcycles doing,
I don't know,
fucking 190 miles an hour.
That one is on April 9th.
Sunday,
April 9th in Argentina at 3:00 PM east coast time.
I'll actually be in San Antonio.
MMM.
And uh,
let's see.
So that game will come on from me at two o'clock.
For me.
It's going to come on at two o'clock and I just have to figure out how the fuck
I'm going to,
uh,
where the hell I'm going to watch it.
I think it's on Fox,
but uh,
I'm totally into this ship.
I've totally into it.
All right.
That's it.
Everybody go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
You conch and a la.
I'll talk to you on Monday ferry.
Go up room with also listen to this music here,
a little bit of musical or music bed here and then we're going to play you some,
uh,
some classic Monday morning podcast that Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from a Thursday or a Monday from the year gone by.
Um,
a lady roommate.
Hey Bill,
huge fan of the show.
Wanted to see if you had any advice for this situation.
I found myself in a little over a month ago.
I moved to Phoenix and moved in with a friend of I edge.
You go up camelback mountain yet.
That's a fucking great hike.
You gotta go up that one.
Somebody dies up there every fucking year,
which always cracks me up to be like alone in the wilderness.
While you can actually see buildings in the distance,
that's gotta be so frustrating.
Um,
little ugly ass fucking roadrunners.
All right.
A little over a month ago,
I moved to Phoenix and moved in with a friend from college.
No real problems there,
but he did have a female college age roommate that he got along with.
So we ended up setting settling on a three bedroom.
All right?
So it's two dudes and a chick.
She's already like a Sitcom.
This is like fucking reverse three's company.
Colin Naga Ahmad [inaudible].
I remember a fucking American was just like that,
you know?
Nice and simple.
I guess it was probably fucked up then.
I was just too young to notice sitting there eating a popsicle.
Look his own.
He's got a buddy dude,
Betty boop,
boop,
Larry's upstairs.
50 years old.
Fucking everything that moves.
Um,
all right.
I only know a few people in town and my work schedule is grueling.
It makes it really hard to meet to too many people over the course of the week.
All right,
so you're setting up your excuse for why you're already fucking your friends
friend.
Alright?
You know,
I work alone.
I can't get to meet people.
Uh,
why go out for pussy when it's right next door?
I get it,
buddy.
I get it.
You know,
it's discovery channel.
Does the line go after the toughest zero,
the fucking wounded one other,
the little baby one or the one walking around wearing the fucking juicy shorts.
Um,
I'm sure by now you've pinpointed the key word in the above paragraph.
Female.
Yes I have sir.
Yes I have.
So you can see where this is going.
My second weekend here,
we all go out get sloppy jalopy drunk and she informs me that she broke up with
their boyfriend of five years.
Oh,
wonderful.
So of course I do the gentlemanly thing and fuck your brains out.
Oh,
you go.
So of course.
Yeah,
I do the gentleman thing and fuck her brains out or flop around like a dead fish
on top of her.
Um,
it's one of those too.
Once I'm done,
I leave,
I go to my room and we don't mention and we don't mention it.
You don't mention it in the morning and it's not awkward at all.
If I had the Allah Lou your song.
Oh,
that's fucking great.
Okay.
Would you guys look down at me if I told you that I was just jealous of this
person right now?
That's fucking perfect.
And the hardest thing is going to be for you to not fuck this up for you not to
develop failing's.
Okay.
You know,
that's going to be a hard one.
But if you could somehow do it,
if you could somehow keep yourself separated.
Okay.
You know,
you could just,
it would be like a,
it'd be like stamps.com having the post office and you fucking apartment.
Now you've got the post ups,
your apartment and now you have this blow job machine also there.
I mean it's tremendous.
Okay.
You know,
and then I got to do is just decide what,
what kind of food you're always going out for and you're really liking.
You buy that appliance speed,
a Panini maker or a fucking cappuccino maker.
You got that stamps.com and the blowjob machine down the hall and I tell you
that's it.
Get the NFL package,
call it a life.
Um,
so anyways,
he goes,
well,
we've gone about doing this for a few weeks now,
but since I'm never home during the week and she works during the day on
weekends,
we don't exactly see each other.
And when we do,
we,
we literally never say anything about it or hint added at all,
et Cetera.
Don't please don't fuck this up.
Okay,
please don't fuck this up.
Okay?
He says,
my question being as this is the first time something like this has happened,
is this a time bomb waiting to happen?
We're all the crazy is going to come flying out like the Ark of the covenant or
is she just rebounding?
And I'm the free and clear until I settle in and find something else.
Keep in mind,
keep in mind that Jesus Christ,
sorry,
didn't go to church today,
has died for rose and is risen from the grave.
He did it all for you.
There's no way for you to thank him
once you give us a bunch of money.
Um,
keep in mind,
I've never been accused of being good looking and she's pretty cute with the
grade a ass on her.
Any advice is appreciated and I guess go fuck yourself.
Um,
okay.
All right.
You did the right thing.
You know you've got a great situation and you don't want to fuck it up.
You know,
this is like the first time I went deep sea fishing and I got a bite and I
looked at the dude next to me,
my it,
right.
What do I do now?
I let it run a little bit.
Let it run a little bit.
Ne bringing it right.
You don't want the same thing.
All right?
So what is your question here?
Is this a time what this is?
Okay.
This is the wildcard that she's a psycho,
but she,
she,
she would've shown her colors by now.
I would think if she was a psycho,
you know it was,
there would have been some sort of,
you know,
God,
you work so much and don't get to see you
or you would have to do on that,
you know,
fucking twisting your arm hair or doing something fucking annoying,
some sort of annoying sort of touching.
Right.
So she hasn't done that.
She's totally putting out the vibe that she's basically in the mindset.
It's this thing seems like it's exactly what it is.
You know,
she was in a relationship for five years,
five years,
man.
She's got to decompress from that.
All right?
She likes to go out and get hammered and get fucked and go to bed and not see
your dumb ass for the whole week.
All right.
Just keep it at that.
This is the deal.
You don't have to bring it up either.
You don't have to bring it up or you just keep it the way it is.
All right?
If she's barely talking to you,
you barely talk to her and you just have fun with it and this is another thing
you do.
All right.
Have Fun with this shit.
What is some things that you always wanted to do with the woman and you haven't
done yet?
This is the girl you do it with.
All right?
And she's going to probably do it with youtube because she doesn't give a fuck
about you,
which is a great thing.
What you have,
sir is a fuck buddy.
Congratulations.
This is your first one.
This is what men dream of.
This is what men really want for,
this is what we want for Christmas.
You know,
if we could just have a fuck buddy,
somebody who was clean with no diseases,
you know,
and somehow then had this pill they could give you that you drank,
you washed it down and it got rid of any sort of fucking guilt.
It will be perfect.
But just single dudes so there's no guilt.
So my,
my thing is just don't,
don't open your mouth and fuck this thing up.
All right?
You got a great thing going.
Okay.
Just keep doing what you're doing.
And,
uh,
the only thing I would correct is this whole thing where you say,
you know,
I'm not that good looking at guy,
work on your self esteem.
She's pretty cute.
Hey,
you know,
good for her.
She's got a nice ass.
Why don't you go fucking do something to it,
but not during the week.
No fucking during the week you focus on your job,
you have a great fucking time.
Now I know it's,
you know,
I guess eventually if you do meet somebody and you start bringing them around,
there's put there as a potential,
but uh,
you just got to nip that shit in the,
but I guess if you actually met somebody that you liked,
uh,
at Jesus and he says,
yeah,
I didn't think about that.
All right,
first,
first things first before we even get over to her.
Uh,
I mean,
does it okay.
Whole new can of worms here,
dude,
you have to be cool first and foremost.
All right.
Because eventually,
you know,
if she meets some other dude,
you got to make sure that you're not going to flip out.
So do not develop any feelings for this girl.
And the only way you're not going to develop any feelings for this girls,
if you see her once a fucking week and your Banger,
okay?
You don't want to know how many brothers and sisters she has,
right?
It's like reservoir dogs.
You guys shouldn't even know each other's names.
Don't you name though to be a fucking,
I don't want even your name.
Yeah,
you don't know.
You don't.
You want that?
All right.
You fucking Mr Pink or whatever.
She's missed a blonde or Mrs Blonde.
Uh,
sorry.
Um,
that's the only thing you got to worry about.
All right,
so,
and I've learned to just be totally fucking upfront and honest.
So if I got some new girlfriend,
I would just tell her what's up.
So what's your deal?
Yeah,
I'm single.
I'm kind of banging my fucking roommate once a week,
you know,
we don't,
it's just sort of a fuck buddy thing.
Oh,
does that make you uncomfortable?
Well,
all right,
well then this relationship isn't going to work because you're already
uncomfortable with me.
Know if I got feelings for you.
I wouldn't keep banging her,
but you know,
I'm not taking it off the table after one fucking trip to Applebee's,
Jesus Christ free pussy.
That's like free shoes for you,
right?
You know,
I dunno.
That's all I all I can tell you dude,
you can't control her.
Who gives a fuck dote?
Someday you're going to be 50 and you got to be married and she's going to be
bitching at you about something you,
if you love her,
you at some point you're just going to be reminiscent going,
you know when my life was the greatest was when I had that little fucking
goddamn three bedroom apartment.
All I had to do was make this amount of money a week and I had some chick once a
week with just fucked my brains out and not talk to me for the other six days.
Goddamn dream.
You got the dream,
sir.
All right,
and I don't know where you're going to wake up,
but enjoy it while it lasts.
Okay.
I hope I answered your question.
I really do.
You're in a hell of a situation.
Enjoy it.
All right,
Kudos to you.
I am jealous.
Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
This is bill burns and this is,
uh,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
This is the official one.
That other one that I just left was a,
was an unofficial and was not,
uh,
was not sanctioned by the board of directors of the Monday morning podcast.
Had a crazy day.
I've been talking all day long.
Uh,
trying to be cute,
trying to be funny,
trying to sell tickets from my theater dates this weekend and I am pretty much
all fucking talked out.
So this is going to be a straight ahead no bull shit.
Let's get right to the meat of the fucking issue podcast because,
uh,
I'm going to the ranger game tonight and uh,
I'm going to a bar first,
which is stupid.
I'm going to get sick,
but I don't know how to say no,
you know,
I don't know how to say no.
What the fuck else am I going to do?
You know,
so disregard the unofficial podcast,
which said that I would be doing this podcast after the hockey game.
Cause I'm not,
I just decided to fuck it.
I'll do a quick 20 minute one within 19 minute intro.
If you're new to my podcast,
I do one of these every Monday and I do them right here on [inaudible] dot com
and uh,
I also do them on my myspace page.
No,
I am not on Facebook.
If you want to know why I'm not on Facebook,
revert to the podcast,
the unofficial one before this.
And even though it's unofficial,
it is my official feeling.
I'll fucking Facebook.
Do you like this?
Is footnotes with this podcast.
All right.
This is the deal,
man.
Every week I do one of these and I answer people's questions.
I read shit that they find underrated.
Overrated.
I give people advice,
I read stories about revenge and whatever else this thing spins into when I
always tell my gigs.
Like for example,
this weekend I'm going to be on April 3rd,
I'm going to be at the lake shore theater in Chicago,
Illinois.
Um,
all the information is on dover.com,
my space.com/bill burr.
It's all up there.
And on a Saturday I am going to be at the uh,
Trump marina.
Isn't that what it is?
I can't remember.
I think that's what it is.
Yeah.
It will be in Atlantic city at the Trump marina.
Why doesn't that sound right when it comes out of my fucking mouth or whatever.
That's what I'm going to say.
I'm going to be Trump marina.
We just added a second show,
which is why I'm doing all this media today,
which is why I'm fucking half asleep.
So I'm going to sign a little bit drunk,
but I'm not,
that kid is this Saturday,
April 4th and I will be working with young Joe de Rosa,
one of the new stars of the Opie and Anthony Show.
Um,
and he will also be on the opie and Anthony show with me as well.
I,
this whole week,
I'm going to be on it on Tuesday,
Wednesday and Thursday of this week.
That would be a March 31st April 1st and April 2nd and Joe to Rose's coming on
on April 2nd.
So there you go.
Look at that.
I got all my hype edge out of the way and like I said,
this is going to be really quick.
All right.
And uh,
let's talk about my gig.
This past weekend I was working at the house of comedy and a St Louis and I had
a great time.
Unbelievable crowds all weekend.
Uh,
my,
uh,
my eight person fan club showed up to members strong and a,
I want to thank them for showing up.
That's the group of people that followed me to Nashville.
And do you guys remember that story when they went to Kansas City?
You want a quick recap because we've patched things up between,
it's actually had a blowout with my fan club.
There's only,
I can't,
who the fuck gets into a fight with their fucking fan club?
All right.
I just like saying I have a fan club.
I feel like a teen idol.
Like it should be singing some song about teenage teenage anx,
you know,
no bill,
we don't deal with my fucking hair slicked back if I still let him to slip back.
You know,
I'm looking over my shoulder,
like a fucking gay actor trying to be straightened.
And then I fucking cat crashed my car.
And Mulholland drive is basically what happened.
My Fan Club last time they saw me,
they went to at least the Saint Louis Chapter.
Um,
uh,
basically they went to Kansas City when I was working in the Improv.
I'll tell you this story really quick.
And uh,
they came in and they were excited and evidently they were being loud.
So I'm sitting in the green room and the bouncer comes back and says,
hey bill,
there's a,
there's a table people out there.
They're really loud.
They seem drunk.
Do you want me to tell him to,
uh,
you know,
sort of chill out a little bit before he go up?
And I go,
sure,
that'd be great.
And evidently the bouncer,
it goes out there and he says to the fan club,
he says,
Hey,
Bill Byrd told you guys to shut the fuck up,
or something like that.
So naturally they were beside themselves and for some reason decided to continue
to drink so they could have a nice rational conversation.
About it after the fucking show.
So the show in,
next thing you know,
I get 20 people coming to me with,
hey,
build written on their shirt and uh,
they're all telling me what a fucking asshole I am and I had nothing to do with
it.
And I explained myself on a podcast about it.
I don't know when the fuck is was,
this was years ago.
And uh,
but anyways,
it's the first time I've met any of them since then.
And they were nice.
They didn't try to kick the shit out of me.
So evidently everything is all good.
So I want to say thanks to them for coming out and also thanks to that crew of
guys from the University of Kansas.
That's right.
Mother fuckers distant right now around a laptop,
high fiving each other,
probably doing drugs,
legal or not legal.
I want to thank all those guys,
those mother fuckers on college,
kid money,
you know,
drove all the way from uh,
basically uh,
the other side of Kansas City to come out to my show,
which was really flattering on college kid money.
Unless they got one rich French,
which they probably do.
There's always one rich front and you act like you're friends with them.
I'm going to blow up this right now.
Act like your fucking friends with them and you're really not,
he just had gas money in the fucking car,
you know,
then all of a sudden you wreck it and then what do you do?
You have the guy who should be in a biker gang,
but for some reason he's still in college.
Welds a new front end to it and you turned it into a float and then you do a
bunch of shit that would be considered a terrorist act and yeah,
with the whole nine 11 Patriot Act,
you'd never get away with it.
Right?
Sound familiar?
All right.
Animal House reference for all you youngsters out there.
All right,
so this is the Monday morning podcast and this is going to be a lean mean one in
these lean mean times of a fucked up economy.
Anybody else who do,
I did the right thing with their money and they're sick of people telling them
that they have to pull themselves up by their bootstraps.
It's like,
no I don't.
No,
I don't.
I have to fucking,
I have to.
What do I have to do?
I don't know what I have to,
I had to pick myself up off the floor because you had dumb fucking ass knocked
me down to it.
I didn't do anything,
you know,
whole all this time and making fun of that MTV cribs lifestyle.
I should have been living in everyone else's.
It doesn't make a fucking difference in the end.
You know,
I'm trying to figure their way out,
man.
I'm trying to get off the wheel was trying to stop running on the wheel and I
can't use fucking bank has got the whole thing sewed up.
If we're going to go is another dick in my face.
There's no way to fucking escape this shit.
I'm really just going to have to work until I'm 106 and then I'm going to die
and then that's going to be the end of it.
You know,
you think I don't have dreams.
I don't want to retire open some fucking stupid ass bar down on the Florida keys
sit there in a Hawaiian shirt.
You know what I mean?
It's,
I just fucking sell drinks to convicted felons and a gay mass murderers score on
the run because they killed the fucking,
sorry,
I can't remember how that one went in front of you.
What Andrew Cunanan referenced there really killed Versace.
Uh,
I saw a really good looking woman sort of down.
You don't,
you don't like when a girl gets like so good looking is so super model looking
that they kind of looked like an alien.
I was actually doing this interview with this guy,
John McCarthy,
who has his own fucking website,
which escapes me.
The name of it escapes me cause I'm half asleep and I did 10 of those interviews
today,
but we were looking at this woman,
we were like,
she's beautiful,
isn't it?
Seems.
Yeah,
she's unique cause like it's kind of looks reptilian.
There's something about like once you're taller than five 11 as a woman and you
still are somehow under 120 pounds,
you know your eyes get really big.
You just,
you walk like literally alien.
He looked,
you know what they look like,
they look cool,
they look like big praying.
Mantises
praying mantises that you want to fuck.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
let's get to the podcast questions.
Like I said,
this is going to be a real quick one.
We'll do this.
We're only 10 minutes in and Mario and the questions.
All right bill,
I love this question by the way,
cause this question needed to be asked.
Bill,
what the fuck is the deal with Ed hardy shirts?
Can everybody just relax,
take a big inhale and then exhale and just be happy that somebody question those
fucking things.
I'm going to read it again so much.
I love this question.
Bill.
What the fuck is the deal with Ed hardy shirts seems like it has become the
uniform of the power tool.
Am I an ass for not realizing these aren't the,
these are the coolest things.
Uh,
wait a minute.
Am I asked for not realizing these are the coolest things ever or am I
accidentally smart for realizing that I don't need to wear a dress shirt with a
drawing of a dragon fucking Buddha,
thanks in advance for help.
So odd.
You couldn't be more right.
I don't,
I don't get those.
You know what those things are going to be,
you know,
every period I'm going to talk about fashion right now,
every period has a moment where somebody where you know,
a style comes out when you know that,
you know,
10,
20 years down the line when they do the dazed and confused movie of that period,
that's like,
you know,
they'll try to act like everybody was wearing that shit.
Jesus Christ built to say what you're trying to say.
But at this way,
I was alive during the 70s but I never wore bell bottoms.
You know what I mean?
I never had a big pink comb in my back pocket with feathered back hair.
Random.
My hair used to be like a fucking Brillo pads so I couldn't do it.
But you know what I'm saying?
Well,
you know,
whenever they do a movie about the 70s everybody looks like that.
You know what I mean?
Everybody dresses like that.
That's what those Ed hardy shirts are.
Those of the horrific fashion mistake of a,
of this time period.
They're fucking horrific.
And not only that,
that whole a bunch of drawing on your shirt.
I wasn't that in like three years ago.
I remember when I was still trying to be young three years ago at a,
a,
at a,
at a very,
uh,
very tipsy 37 years old.
I,
you know,
I started wearing shirts like that.
There were,
those shirts were initially for the people who weren't man enough to get a
tattoo over their entire torso.
And I remember like,
literally like,
I think like a year and a half ago,
I was just like,
you know what?
These are these fucking bedazzled shirts with the eagles and the fucking,
uh,
I dunno anteaters on him.
Whatever the hell they are with all these like prison tattoo designs,
this shit's over.
And evidently it isn't.
They're continuing with them and ed hardy,
he doesn't dare like these.
It's like those awful designs and bright colors you don't,
seems like they would wear them at the growing up Gadi sorta kids seems like
they would wear,
you know,
they'd wear them and they'd still get pussy.
You know,
cause they got the,
they got the end two you got at the end,
they go red.
Now you get the attitude that movie fast times at Ridgemont high.
Every movie references I'm going to make is going to be fucking 30 years old at
this point.
All right.
You're absolutely right.
I don't know what to deal with Ed hardy shirts are the fucking horrific and not
even Armenian guys wear them.
They,
at least as far as I know,
they seem to wear those other bizarre but there bizarrely designed and they step
out of Maseratis or at least to Armenian guys did it.
A car wash.
I saw in La.
So now that becomes every Armenian guy in my mindset,
but that's even fucking make sense.
I don't care.
Okay.
I'm working on five hours sleep and I've been running my mouth.
I'll fucking deck.
Uh,
and yes,
I will be giving excuses every five seconds for this podcast.
All right,
question number two,
Bill,
I'm recently new to your podcast,
but thanks to Itunes,
the uh,
my podcast question is,
do you follow the World Cup soccer in general?
If so,
do you root for any team specifically?
And if not,
you should consider the Seattle sounders then come up to Seattle for a show and
the game,
the Seattle sounders.
Alright.
Just when I thought Ed Hardy was going to be the worst thing I could picture in
my mind,
I'm just picturing the crew of people who sat around a fucking conference table
then came up with the name for your soccer team.
Do.
I'm not shitting on soccer before I trashed the name of your team.
Let's get back to the first question.
Do I follow World Cup soccer now?
I don't.
I would love to.
You know,
I,
I've tried to follow that.
Uh,
what the Premier League,
I tried to get into it cause I think it is cool as hell.
And I actually,
I actually liked soccer,
you know,
I actually didn't like it.
I know a lot of Americans don't like to shit,
but I actually like it,
but I don't like American soccer just because Americans don't seem to be into it
that much.
So it just kinda seems like you're watching the WWE NBA.
There's no excitement in the crowd and you know,
I can't get excited if no one else was excited cause I'm codependent.
So,
uh,
the only time I followed the World Cup is when they actually have the World Cup.
And when I watch it,
I just root for the countries that I am.
Um,
you know,
that my ancestors were,
I guess German,
Irish with a little bit of English.
So I've pretty much just,
I root for Germany because I think it's funny,
it's just funny to root for Germany to be in a crowd of people rooting for
Germany.
It's just so fucking Cliche,
like Naziesque,
you know what I mean?
There's no way to fucking sit there in a crowd full of people be cheering on
Germany and somehow not feel like you're advocating the policies of Adolph
Hitler.
That's what I,
that's what I like about Rudy for Germany is the,
he just start laughing halfway through it.
Like,
Hey,
wait,
am I not to be,
oh,
wait a minute.
No,
no,
I'm just waiting for the stock team.
That's right.
And uh,
I also root for the teams in South America because evidently if they miss a
penalty shot,
they go home and they get executed.
So,
um,
but you know,
that can only be one winner.
So getting back to the Seattle sounders,
I get it.
What,
because uh,
what is,
what is outside of us at Puget sound?
I know there's some sort of sound,
I just hate that fucking word.
I gotta look it up again.
What
the fuck is this sound?
You know something?
I don't know that I could define any sort of body of water other than an ocean.
I know what an ocean is,
right?
I know what the fucking ocean is.
Let me try to psych myself up so I can answer this.
And Ocean is a,
it's a lot of water.
Water between continents.
What else does it have?
Well,
it has salt water.
I'm a fucking moron.
What does it sound?
We're just going to type sound and let's see what happens here.
Sound is a vibration transmitted.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Hang on a second.
Sound.
Let's just write sound water.
Water's sound effects.
Geography.
The glacier produces a sound speed of sound and how sound in air differs.
Sound water productions.
What the fuck?
All right.
How about this?
Let me,
let me write it and then you got to be a moron.
It's how you find shit on the Internet.
What is a sound?
Enter web definition.
Sound,
sound,
investments.
You fucking cunt.
Spelling it wrong.
How do you spell sound for water?
Here it is.
Sound geography.
Let's go to Wikipedia.
God knows they're credible and geography.
A sound or a seaway is a large sea or ocean inlet larger than a bay.
All right.
What the fuck is an inlet and inlet is a narrow body body of water between
islands or leading inland from a larger banal.
I'm not going to read the rest of it cause it's just going to get confusing.
I liked that.
An inlet is a narrow body of water between islands.
Okay,
so a sound is a big inlet,
uh,
bay.
I don't give a fuck.
Jesus Christ.
I like this.
She get a definition than every other word is highlighted because they know
you're fucking stupid.
So geography is sound or a seaway is a large sea or ocean inlet larger than a
bay.
So I guess it is salt water.
Okay.
I sort of get what that is.
So they're the sounders.
All right,
let's look up Seattle sounders.
Let's look this up.
This is exciting,
isn't it?
Seattle sounder.
Jeez.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
it's a small club when they're not even the number one fucking thing there.
The third,
that third lead on that Seattle sounders.
And let's see,
do they have history?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
You guys are really into that awful green and blue up there.
Why do you guys always have that?
Why does everything have to look like algae when it comes to your sports teams?
You know,
give her the algae isn't a good team color.
Um,
all right,
let's get,
let's get the stop fucking car.
I actually liked soccer and I'm trashing.
Did I mention the shout out to the people from Kansas University?
Let me get back to fucking anyway.
What the fuck are we here?
All right.
Anyways,
well here's the kid hyping up the Seattle sounders game.
Ah,
there are new mls expansion team up here and the atmosphere was electric.
I suppose I'm a little biased in that soccer is easily the greatest sport in the
world.
But having been over in Germany for the 2006 World Cup,
the sounders game felt oddly similar.
Okay.
Now do you work for the Seattle sounders?
Are you really going to say going to Germany for the 2006 World Cup,
that going to a home game for the Seattle sounders was equivalent to that?
I don't know.
Evidently he's saying that it's a shit and he should have and you only go up
there and you have a good time because you'll be surrounded by a sea,
not a sound,
not an inlet of,
of green.
That was stupid.
Why we just said that.
I see not a sound,
not a bay.
That's what I should've said.
Inlet.
That didn't make sense.
Did it cause an inlet is why she she and what doesn't make sense,
doesn't it?
What does an inland,
I can't even remember.
See,
this is why I sucked in school and inlet and outlet is a small,
straight sort of fucking body of water between.
What if this is say,
well listen to this and I want you to,
I hope you're enjoying this because I know you're fucking laughing,
but just know that you dressed like you were in the village people,
let's get onto the revenge stories.
Shall We?
Uh,
we'll probably do rate underwear because I didn't close with the revenge stories
cause he thinks is so fucking long.
And not to mention there's a guy talking a little bit of shift about some of
your other revenge stores.
All right,
let's get with overrated,
underrated.
All I have this week is one overrated because this is going to be the stripped
down.
Send me a text message.
I like the stripped down version.
Okay.
Over,
I got to end this thing.
It's five minutes,
so I got to hurry here for us.
I'm going to miss my drinking time.
Overrated.
Uh,
thanks to the end and we'll talk [inaudible] I got an over rate of four.
You fucking relationships.
Why in the hell can't guys get out?
Get on the damn boat already.
The single guys have it down.
Wind Dynam fuck him and fucking leave.
I guess it's like you said,
uh,
I'm sorry.
People like I can't,
I,
you know,
I usually suck at reading.
I'm just relieving more sign of Denim and you fucking leave.
That's how the single guys do it.
I guess it's like you said,
I think it was Tupac podcasts ago or so.
You feel the gravitational pull to get married and have kids.
I guess that's guys had the same poll about being dumb enough to try and make a
relationship work.
Uh,
yeah,
I think there's a lot of truth to that.
I think what you should do is you should just remain signals for your entire
twenties,
you know,
and right time,
right about the time you're like 30,
then you know,
once you get all your fucking out of your system,
then you can just kind of be like,
all right,
I need to,
you know,
you're going to want to hang with somebody at some point.
You know,
you don't want to be the old guy in the bar like me.
Like I'm about to be 45 minutes,
you know,
hey,
there's sugar,
you know,
column women by Old,
old rat pack names.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's get onto the,
uh,
the revenge story.
I'm going to read this guy's first cause he's talking a little bit of trash and
I liked this guy's coming out.
Come,
he's coming out.
Really a confident.
All right.
Revenge story number one,
Bill.
It seems as if all the,
it seems like all their events,
stories that you've been reading on the podcast lately have been sent sent by a
bunch of pansies that take the pussy passive form of revenge and fuck with
somebody's car.
Shit like that is lame and a pathetic attempt to get back at someone.
What they really need to do is take a more aggressive approach.
Here is my revenge store.
I want you guys to know this.
I haven't even,
I haven't even read this one yet.
All right.
I just saw that intro and I'm like,
well,
with an intro like that,
this has to be the best revenge story we've heard so far.
So with that,
let's all judge this guys revenge story as I read it for the first time and I
want you to know there's things like fucking nine pages long.
God Damn people,
I'll tell you revenge is a quick,
what the fuck did I just do?
Revenge is not a quick thing here.
Hang on.
I just accidentally hit the wrong button.
All right,
I'm back.
here we go.
The revenge story.
All right,
fill.
This happened a few years ago when I was 17 and working at a fast food joint one
night I was closing the place and I was rolling a blunt at one of the tables to
smoke after I got off of work and other words.
He was a typical fucking fast food kit.
So anyways,
a new,
a new kid that just started working there a couple of weeks before thinking he
was doing the right thing.
Oh wait dude,
you read,
you know half the shit isn't my problem.
You guys don't write in complete sentences.
And it was a new kid,
this kind of rolling and a fucking join the goddamn table and the new kid
thought he was doing the right thing and he turned me into the manager on duty
that night.
The manager laughed at him because he couldn't care less about what I was doing,
all the fact that his employees smoked weed.
That isn't that Nice,
but a great manager.
Next day when I go into work,
that same manager tells me what happened the night before.
I'm not pissed,
but I'm all like,
you know what the fuck does this guy would run to the manager and think they
need some sort of whistleblower.
I decided so I decided that the guy needs to learn his lesson.
Jesus Christ.
Nice setup so far enough for you guys.
I'm enjoying this.
So anyways,
I call up a friend of mine to get what I need and when the kid goes on his break
in order to lunch,
when he's not looking,
I dropped it.
Two hits of acid,
I brought two with me and his drink.
Okay.
When I read that wrong,
I got two hits of acid.
Okay,
you're not you guys.
Can you proof read these fucking things so I don't sound like the dumbest person
on you know what he did?
He took two hits of acid.
He dropped him in his fucking fruit punch.
So anyways,
he sits down and he starts eating and I go back to work and I wait for it to
kick in and the entertainment to start.
All right,
I'm starting to get just guests.
The vibe with this story.
Evidently,
when he says your king the car,
he doesn't mean that you're a pussy because you didn't do something face to
face.
Evidently this maniac doesn't think you took it far enough.
All right,
back to the story.
An hour later when he clocks back in,
I can tell it's beginning to kick in heart.
I watch the do gooder con starts to trip balls and freaks everyone out.
That's a trip balls and freaks everyone out.
Nobody else knows what is going on with the guy,
so they lock him in the back manager's office,
so this is really dangerous because he didn't know he was probably never done
drugs.
He probably thought he was going crazy.
It's really dangerous and fucking hilarious.
All right.
When he's in there,
he really starts to lose his shit and tear the place apart.
My manager calls the cops and when they get there they go back and cuff.
They go back and cut them and put them in the back of a squad car.
There's a lot of confusion in the place and everyone tries to figure out what
the hell just happened.
The cop starts to question everyone to try and figure out just what went on,
but I play it off dumb just like everyone else saying.
He just started to act crazy too.
What do you have a life of crime?
You're playing that shit off,
not worry that you're going to get caught or you want to work release from
prison.
Anyways,
after taking everyone's statements,
the cops leave and caught the guy off.
He never did come back to work or even show his place face in that place again.
Don't know if it was out of embarrassment,
confusion to what happened,
sang on fusion to what happened or outright fear of the place,
so I don't know.
Whatever happened to them,
it's still is the best 15 bucks that I ever spent.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
that's fucking hardcore,
man.
I like
it.
You confused as I dunno why.
I Dunno if he was embarrassed.
If he was confused to do.
You don't think he figured out what the fuck happened and he wasn't able to put
fucking one and one together and make to how big.
That's what I have to say really.
Instead,
rather than say,
put two and two together and get four,
this is how we,
this is one in one.
Well,
let's see,
I read it out so many people.
Do you think he read it out for doing drugs in the last 24 hours?
Then all of a sudden he starts fucking tripping.
Wow.
I'm such a sadistic fuck.
Maybe there would be a part me that would really enjoy that.
Especially if he was like,
ah,
like always doing the right thing.
You know what I mean?
You know people who always fuck up in life just really hate people who are doing
the right thing.
You know?
I told him,
I talked to you about these people,
they called conch and as much as I hate cons,
I really am one when it comes to certain kinds of people,
I have no tolerance for people who are pussies.
I don't,
and it's not because I'm a tough guy,
probably reminds me of a certain part of my personality that I don't like.
But in general,
you know who goes on and tell somebody,
you know what?
Fuck that guy.
What was he trying to take your position at the fryer layers so it could be
fucking Douche bag or the month.
Wow.
That really must have psychologically damaged and made me think about that.
You know his whole life,
that Mama's boy,
he probably always like,
you know,
and he is that his sandwich?
You now we swim and he didn't waste 15 minutes.
Who?
That's very good.
Mikey always got rewarded for it and then he fucking ratchet you up.
Hey,
you know that fucking,
you know guy over there smoking weed and then the manager.
So it's like,
yeah,
that's what you do.
We work in a fast food joint.
Do you think this was our dream in life for the love of God?
Somebody gives me a hit because I can't take the fucking pain or reality
anymore.
Don't you go mop something up?
You're a little pussy.
That's probably what happened the next day.
It's like,
Geez,
I went home,
talked to his mom.
I couldn't believe it.
Gallery Jamey.
I mean he was doing,
he had a marijuana cigarette.
Well don't you worry you did the right thing.
Okay.
And you just stay away from him and you go to work tomorrow and you make sure
you do a good show
and then it goes to work and he fucked a fucking puts the date rape drug in
there,
the date rape drug.
You know what I'm saying?
He puts acid and that Jesus Christ,
he never even had mentioned.
You've never even had a sip of beer in.
The first thing happens to is to hit the athletes.
I never took acid that God,
thank God.
Thank God I never ran out.
Somebody doing drugs.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
here's,
here's another revenge story.
I'm going to read this one,
then I got to wrap it up.
Uh,
hey bill.
I'm with you on the no revenge rule.
People suffer.
Oh,
this wasn't even a revenge thing.
This is just a question.
This guy needs some advice.
This,
this falls into the ass bill portion of the podcasts.
The advice people like to ask me for advice,
even though I'm a fucking moron.
Let me just read this whole thing cause uh,
all right.
Anyways,
I was writing to you to talk about,
okay,
here,
here's the property s uh,
he needs some advice.
Anyways,
Bill,
I was writing to you to talk about my cons,
have a girlfriend and hopefully to get some advice.
I love how con is just become the catchphrase of the podcast here.
Anyways,
me and my girlfriend have been together for about two and a half years.
We knew each other as teenagers,
um,
along with some other people she dated.
Um,
she did it,
one of our friends and he eventually moved on and gotten married.
Me and her remain friends and eventually we became close.
We started dating.
She isn't the best friend.
Well I figured that.
Consider your calling or a con.
Yeah,
because she had a couple of things that annoyed yet she has the best girlfriend
but I have become pretty,
pretty comfortable having her around and her two kids,
not for me,
love or two kids,
not for me.
They loved me and we have become quite the family.
Here is where Shit went wrong
recently we visited our friends in New York and we are all partying and shit and
I got a horrible headache and sit down on the couch to rest it up.
I was out of it for like 30 minutes and I wake up to a nightmare.
I hear my friend in the kitchen hitting on my girlfriend.
Wow.
If it's as if that's not bad enough,
she's into this shit and encourage him,
encouraging him and flirting back.
After I had all I could take,
I walked into the kitchen and they made the oh shit face when they looked at me,
but I didn't say anything.
Then I didn't say anything.
Then in there the next night for possibly or possibly the same nights since that
was hammered every day I was the fair,
me and my girlfriend go to bed in the guest room while we are laying there.
She gets up to go to the bathroom and after she didn't return,
after about 15 minutes,
I opened the door and what do I see him and her standing there alone in the
hallway,
having a quiet conversation.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
this is getting creepy.
Here's her story.
She was just entertaining herself and it wasn't going to go anywhere.
She feels she didn't sleep with him or anyone else.
So I'm overreacting.
So I'm overreacting by considering breaking up,
considering all we really,
she have to lose.
Oh,
considering all that you guys have to loose.
Yeah.
It's really her with the two fucking kids.
All right.
So anyways,
she's been walking around crying and I'm upset about the shit she has told me
she was sorry and it will never happen again.
She has been pretty much worshiping me the last few days and the shit is
starting to eat away at me.
I also know that I purchased most of the shit in this house and if slash when we
separate I'll be taking most of it with me and that is going to make it a lot
more difficult and painful for her and her kids at this point I'm like,
fuck all of this and I am ready to leave.
I'm ready to leave and shit,
but honestly I'm starting to feel like a real douche for not being able to get
past this shit.
The kids will be devastated and they are pretty much doomed once I leave because
I am pretty much the glue that holds this family together.
At the same time,
I feel like if she would do this shit after years,
what kind of hope does that give us for the future?
What kind of relationship can we have app to some shit like this?
I would love some feedback on this bill.
Even though you never read my letters during the podcast insert guiltier just
telling me what you think I should do in this situation.
All right dude.
A year in that classic halfway point between emotion,
you know,
for your feelings,
for the kids,
you're in the halfway point between that and knowing exactly what the fuck you
need to do and you're doing when you need to do,
you need to reach out to people who are going to re affirm what you know in your
heart of hearts.
What you have to do is you have to get the fuck out of there.
You gotta get out of there.
All right.
Do you think that's the first guy she hit on?
You know,
and if she's hitting on guys,
that means she's probably fucking other guys.
And if she's not,
she's going to end.
Right now she's just in a panic mode and she's in a panic mode,
not because she's worried about losing you because of all that other bullshit
that you mentioned because you sound like you're the most responsible of the
people there.
And the only fucking hope her kids have is that you'll stick around because she
is a,
I dunno,
she doesn't have her shit together.
Um,
you got to get out,
dude.
You got to get out and you know you,
you might be good for the kids right now,
but eventually you're not going to be because of the misery that you're going to
have.
Being in a relationship with somebody that you can't trust as far as you can
fucking throw him is eventually gonna rub off on how you feel about the whole
situation.
And it's going to be really hard for you not to be a fucking douche around the
coast.
Kids,
you probably gonna start drinking and eventually you're going to start a fucking
relationship.
And the longer you're there,
the more shit you're going to buy.
This is what you gotta do.
You gotta give yourself fucking six weeks,
all right?
Just break it up in two week increments.
The first two weeks is going to be brutal.
Just cry on the floor with a pint of fucking Haagen daas like a little bitch and
get through it.
And every time you want to call that fucking cunt that you can't trust anymore,
you call a friend of yours.
Instead,
you call a buddy of yours to kind of buddy who's gonna fucking take you out
drinking and gets you back in the fucking game.
That's what you do.
All right?
And you do that and turn that time.
The last fucking thing you do is get into another relationship.
All right?
Don't fucking do that.
Don't do the J.
Lo,
we get out of that and you jump into something else.
Fuck that.
All right?
You stay fucking single,
you know,
and just just get through six fucking weeks in gradually,
and then after two weeks goes by,
you know what I mean?
You start having a life.
You'll start going down to the park,
playing Frisbee with your next door neighbor.
I don't know what the fuck you'll start filling up the time.
That's all it is.
And the breakup haven't been,
you know,
after like a few days,
unless you really love somebody,
you're already getting past them.
What you're really trying to do is wondering,
well what the fuck did I do during all this time?
How did I use to fill up my free time?
And that's what you got your boys for.
They'll take you out,
go drink and go to games,
you know,
by the big fucking dust,
real size box of condoms,
just fucking,
you know,
Bang away,
do all this shit.
You got to do it.
But Dude,
you got to get out of that relationship.
You know,
you got to get out of the relationship and it sucks.
But you know what,
dude?
It's a fucking,
it's a 20 minute conversation.
20 minutes.
What you have to say takes fucking 30 seconds,
but you got to deal with fucking the next 20 minutes,
all her bullshit trying to use all these different techniques to try and get you
to stay.
She's going to go with the guilt.
He's going to go with the Stereo.
She's going to go with anger.
She's gonna fucking unload her female fucking gun of emotion that you and you
just have to stick to your fucking,
you gotta stick to your guns.
I'm out.
I'm out cause you fucked up.
You fucked up.
I can't trust you.
The relationship is over.
Relationship is over.
It's them.
Not only were you hitting on another guy hitting on my best friend,
you fucking cunt,
you untrustworthy fucking con.
And you let the balls to sit here and act like I'm going to fucking stay with
you.
Are you out of your fucking mind?
Wait a minute.
Strike that.
Don't say that means shit.
Don't say that means shit cause then then you don't do it.
Don't do it like that.
Just say,
look,
I can't trust you.
You know what?
Yeah.
Fuck that.
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
You know what you gotta do.
All right,
but don't,
don't,
don't get sucked into a,
you know,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
Fight with her.
Right.
And she's going to do the usual shit that women always do.
Once she gets to the anger thing,
then uh,
she,
she'll go with,
she'll go with the usual chill somehow.
She'll question your sexuality,
your,
your ability and bed.
She'll probably do that.
Well maybe if you fucking blah,
blah,
wouldn't be hitting on your friend.
She's just going to do that in a last ditch.
Hope that you're going to turn around blaster in the fucking face so she can get
a little more money out of you and you can go to jail and she can keep your
fucking playstation.
So don't get sucked into that.
When she says that remark,
just be like,
yeah,
you know what?
Yeah,
I guess I guess I do suck in bed.
So you know,
have fun fucking my friend.
You know?
You seem like you really want to,
you know,
or whatever.
That was the lane mostly.
That was good.
Okay.
Don't get sucked into that.
Don't get sucked into any sort of domestic violence thing.
All right.
I'm not trying to judge you,
but that's a really white tress sort of situation.
You're involved in there where you got this,
you know we dude,
you said in the beginning of that you fucking thing.
Yeah,
I'm Kinda,
I'm only kind of into this girl and she's got two fucking kids.
You know what I mean?
You got to stay single,
dude.
You got to figure out what the fuck is with you that you got yourself into this
mess to begin with.
All right?
But do it.
It could have been worse.
You could have fucking,
you could add up.
Kids were there,
he could have been married.
They could have been who?
She could have been fucking poison in you every morning.
You know those girls,
they don't know how to break up with you.
So they started putting fucking dead cyanide in it and you got them rice.
All right dude.
I'm telling you,
get the fuck out.
You know what to do.
Alright?
Get the fuck out.
You call one of your friends.
Be listened to.
What?
I got to get out of this situation.
It stops.
So I'm going to need you over the next six weeks.
Anytime I call you and I'm like,
I need to go out booze and you gotta be there.
You and your fucking liver have got to be there for me.
You know?
That's what you gotta do.
All right,
there you go.
I know I just said the same thing for fucking 20 minutes,
but you know I been in that situation never with the two kids,
but you got you got,
you gotta go,
Dude.
You gotta go.
All right.
Good.
Grasshopper that make me proud and send me an email in the week and tell me that
you got the fuck out of there.
All right.
That's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast.
God bless all of you.
Uh,
hope to see out of one of my shows.
No.